okay
i'm gonna drop you now no wait
the kill is always new i have just
learned that cult has betrayed us this
is dead
[Music]
the isle of blackberries experienced a
cataclysmic event which towards the
fabric of space and time what kind of
[ __ ] the world is this
[Music]
done playing this your way it's the
culture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
death loop is gamespot game of the year
for 2021
so to join me to talk about how we
landed at this decision as well as why
we love this game so much i've got tamor
hussein who reviewed the game uh
managing editor of gamespot hi tim
hi how are we doing
game of the year let's go i'm sure there
will be no dissent i'm sure no one in
the comments will have other things to
say about this
um but yeah this is game sports game of
the year 2021 in a year packed with
a lot of contenders we thought it was
going to be
a lighter year and it definitely for a
long time felt like a light year but
when it came to sitting down and talking
over the best games of the year it was
surprisingly jam-packed and it was a
close race and ultimately what swan get
was
a lot of heartfelt a lot of emotional
and a lot of passionate discussions
um so for people who might want some
insight into into kind of the format we
take the game of the year discussion
quite seriously obviously not too
seriously because we are people who
love games and don't want to
escalate some weird nonsense but like we
spent weeks kind of collating everyone's
top tens we work to give them all a
ranking and collecting points
attached to them depending on where they
appeared in top 10 rankings and then
gathered together
across multiple time zones
multiple days and talk through each of
the
games one by one and presented cases for
why they think they should be in the top
ten
um not in the top ten in the top five
and then ultimately we all made a case
for games as game of the year based on
the discussions
death loop came out as number one
um and i'm glad that it did yeah me too
so uh we're here today to chat a little
bit about it because i think you and i
are the biggest sort of arcane fans on
staff certainly two of the most vocal
people when we were having the
deliberations
overall i mean it was the clear standout
game of the year for me i
was so i just unbelievably impressed
with it and i think what really struck
me about death loop is just how elegant
it is and how in a year of time loop
games like forgotten city
loop hero in a way i guess you could say
is a sort of time loop game
this like definitely managed to stand
above the crowd and i think the way that
did that is that it was so elegant it
had the potential to be a very confusing
affair but the way that it was laid out
the way that its systems worked and fed
into each other and constantly felt like
you were having meaningful progression
as well as on top of it all having like
a cast of characters who i think for
arcane games in particular were way more
human and you could identify with them
more than ever and like the fact that
colt was an amnesiac
hitman assassin who is who's you know
kind of learning about the world as much
as you are with him just it was all this
really compelling package that i
loved so so much and i say that as a
huge fan of arcane games it was amazing
to see this sort of evolution of things
that they have done before and it all
worked out so well for death loop uh but
tam you reviewed the game for us uh and
it was also like
any other hint that this might get game
of the year did get a 10 out of 10 from
us a coveted 10 out of 10. can you
go through you know what that review
process was like as well as why you feel
death loop was so deserving
not just of game of the year but of that
that 10 out of 10.
yeah so before we jump into that as a
point of clarification 10 out of 10
doesn't mean perfection
um there's a lot of there was a lot of
dissent towards us giving and there
always is giving a game a 10 out of 10
and that's fine people have different
opinions of things but the important
thing to remind people is 10 out of 10
doesn't mean perfection it means to me
something exceptional and something that
i feel like
everyone or you should make an effort to
experience this because it's important
and that's how i approach it i think
what is
really interesting to me and the way i
frame
my kind of reasoning and thinking for
and our reasoning and thinking as a team
for why it it is game of the year i
framed it as a magic trick
um and the idea of it being magic tricks
are incredible right like it doesn't
matter who you are um you can be an
adult you can be a child you can be
somewhere in between you could be you
know
any level of cynical magic tricks have
this unique ability of
just tearing down any boundaries like
you watch a magic trick and it inspires
a child like all like even i say like
even the most stoic people
they
they kind of break down in front of a
magic trick and they need they're wowed
by it right it's like wow this is
incredible that was
is that child like wonder where you
forget all life's worries or you forget
the rules of life and the rules of
nature for a moment and believe that
something truly extraordinary has
happened
and
death loop feels like a magic trick is
happening in front of your eyes so the
thing that this game does differently is
it gives us the second part of the magic
trick that we want most but so very
rarely are given because magicians like
to keep their magic secret and that is
like we ask ourselves after seeing the
trick how did you do that this is a game
about arcane showing us how they do
their magic tricks
they take the very design of the game is
taking the things that everyone comes to
their games for
the immersive worlds the kind of
clockwork nature the many interlocking
mechanics the stealth the action the
powers the guns the puzzles within
puzzles the
you know the clockwork mansions the gin
dosh locks that kind of stuff and
it gives it to you piece by piece by
piece until you understand it and
you build the jigsaw puzzle yourself and
by the time you're done building it you
have this incredible understanding of
how they put their world together and
then along with that they have this time
loop mechanic this you know they they go
to paints to not try and
pigeonhole their game and it's easy to
understand why but if we wanted to do
that this kind of roguelike uh kind of
uh approach to it the action game the
stealth game
and you pick up the individual pieces of
it and you start to put it together and
then you're able to look at the whole of
it and understand how it one part
connects to the next and how you can
best move through it i think in a way to
take what you just said there and to
kind of put it towards another point
about why i think death loop is so
special is that it really respects the
player in a way that a lot of other
games don't like it respects the play
like the hand holding to get you up to
speed with how the game works they
they show you a lot in the early hours
and then they trust the player to be
able to take all those concepts take
those mechanics and then form and forge
their own path like they trust the
player in order to if they want to
explore they encourage that exploration
and part of it is as you were saying
with like combat you feel like you're
not pigeonholed into being oh like you
clean hands ghost i can you know in one
loop or even in just in one district at
one time of day i can go all guns
blazing and then the next i can sneak
through and at no point does the game
ever penalize you for that the game
encourages this exploration and
experimentation
and ultimately the way that it also
really respects the player is that at no
point does anything ever feel wasted
there are always there's always a chance
like there's there's another slab to
find there is another lead to follow
there's another weapon to get and then
the way that you your actions um you
know you can then infuse those things
and take them with you and build
a bigger better more powerful cult to
take into the next loop i think it's
just endlessly rewarding and so yeah you
have this end goal of defeating all the
visionaries and breaking the loop and
like that's the main thing you've been
told to do throughout the whole thing
but
also you have
just so much more to do and like there
are puzzles in there that are fun to
explore but you can totally ignore them
if you choose to and it's just
endlessly rewarding yeah and i think
that one thing that is perhaps a tangent
but like
arcane is a studio that's always been
punching above its weight um it's easy
to forget because they're owned by
bethesda and now microsoft
it feels like they're a massive team and
they have two studios uh leon and
austin and you know they collaborate but
like they're not a massive team it's not
a
relatively speaking compared to a lot of
other aaa games their team is relatively
speaking smaller much much smaller but
they it never feels like that they make
games that are no they never feel like a
you know anything
less than a triple a experience yeah and
it's also i mean
the way that arcane keeps pushing
themselves with like each new game has
something
just you know they take that formula and
they just build on it and just make
something even better and so i think one
of the things that i particularly love
most about death loop is the fact that
you know instead of having this kind of
uh
quiet
protagonist that you kind of pour
yourself into i mean emily and corvo
eventually would have a few lines but
never anything sort of meaningful no
real
big powerful personality that you could
be like oh yeah that's an emily line or
that's a corvo line it's like i felt
like colt was a person and i thought the
writing was so sharp and so funny and it
was so clever the fact that he and
juliana would would be like pretty
pretty much the only people who would
remember things across loops and seeing
the way that their relationship would
grow the way they would talk to each
other and the way that they had this
playful cat and mouse and that was what
drew me uh through the story like if
ever i felt like i would
you know go off the beaten track a
little bit too much and maybe not devote
as many loops to uh to actually the
story that would be the thing that would
bring me back
to it and i i loved those characters so
so much and like even even the
visionaries like they're all god awful
people but you know alexis dorsey i just
you know i love to hate him and i think
it's it's been a real triumph for them
in terms of in terms of writing so
yeah the characterization like a lot of
it is subtle and a lot of it is overt
and i think it works on multiple levels
on the subtlety level like the lines
that are happening in between loops and
during loops that
give this the relationship between them
nuance and history without playing their
hand and showing their hand and and
revealing too much um the the kind of
thread of who they are and what they
mean to each other is something that
they kind of use to string you along
through the entire game and there is an
art to giving you just enough to keep
you on the hook and
they pretty much nail it here that's the
subtle stuff and then the overt stuff is
something that i think deserves to be uh
recognized as the representation of it
um that is involved like colt and
juliana are black characters and
obviously we are not the people to to to
kind of speak at length about this there
are various um people out there and
there's been a lot of writing and videos
to discuss the importance of it but we'd
be remiss if we didn't actually point it
out and say that that factored into our
decision and the reason it factored in
was because not only was their
representation but
it felt so
effortless and it felt natural which
wouldn't have been the case like this is
something probably they they worked so
hard on this is a game that i feel
arcane knows is not for everyone like
and that is kind of something that they
factored into design and and haven't
spoken to them um they knew that not
everyone's gonna love it and not
everyone's gonna
feel the way we feel about it and it is
going to be a divisive game and for
arcane in speaking to
dingo the the director and sebastian and
dana and various other people who worked
on the game
um they just wanted a few people to like
it they just wanted it to connect with a
certain amount of people and if that was
the case that is um good enough for them
and it definitely did and the thing i'll
say is you might be out there thinking
how did this game win game of the year
it's it's it is divisive but i'd ask you
to remember that all the most
divisive games are usually the ones that
have the most impact and are remembered
as being landmark moments for me
the thing that made me fight for it is
like thinking back to other games that i
felt were divisive and the impact
they've had on my life stuff like
sakura stuff like demon souls you know
stuff like breath of the wild is a
divisive game
you might think no it isn't but yes it
is there was a time when people said
this game is weird and it doesn't make
any sense an open world zelda game
that's not what zelda is and it is one
of the greatest games of all time there
was a time when people said
dark souls demon souls too hard not you
know or like unplayable for the average
gamer
people really did not like those
experiences and look what they have
become so yeah death loop is divisive
maybe you don't like it but i feel like
it's a landmark moment and i said this
in my write up but def loop is also a
template a lesson a masterclass on how
to design an arcane game and you might
think why would people want to know that
and the reason people would want to know
that is because
no other developer comes close to making
immersive sims the way that arcane does
they're untouchable
and they're not hiding the secrets of
that magic anymore they are showing you
how to do it and that is what death loop
is and i feel like going forward there
are going to be
designers developers that are empowered
by playing this game and the industry is
going to be better off because of that
couldn't agree more well they have it
that's why
we chose death loop as our game of the
year as you would have seen at the top
of this video uh we did manage to give
uh the lovely folks at arcane the trophy
uh we'll leave you with a little little
clip from the rest of that uh that kind
of trophy hand over um but term
uh if folks want to read your review
read your write-ups where should they go
where can they find you
they should go to gamespot.com you can
find my review there which i'll go in
depth about uh why i liked death loop
and and the the score is there it's a 10
out of 10. there's also a video review
on youtube.comgamesport
if you want more recent if you just go
to the home page you'll probably find
the best of category or it should be on
the homepage for quite some time you can
read a kind of reflection on death loop
some many many months later and
ultimately why a kind of justification
and explanation for why we felt it was
ultimately game of the year for 2021
and you can find me on twitter at
tomorrow h
you can find me on twitter at lucy james
games i cut that video review so some of
that gameplay is mine if you want to go
judge it um a lot of it is terms as well
uh thank you so much for watching uh we
have all of our kind of best of the year
lists up so best xbox games we have best
playstation nintendo pc as well as our
overall 10 best games of 2021 right here
on gamespot thanks for watching see you
in 2022.
okay so when we were setting up this
interview and we were talking to you
guys we said that uh we're making a
video
about a bunch of games and celebrating
them released this year that was a lie
um we're actually not doing that
we set up this interview just to talk to
you
just because we wanted to give you
something
so do you want to go and hand it over
hello
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
wow
oh we are so proud that uh
yeah we are so happy thank you thank you
very much yeah this is this is amazing i
mean honestly like i know everyone's
already said this but we never expected
this type of reception like we always
had faith i mean i always had faith
personally and i think everyone would
agree we always had faith in the
project and believe that
it would
sort of stand on its own two legs and be
something that we could be proud of um
but yeah we're just we're just really
elated that uh the community and and
everyone is uh is into our game this
game is uh is very special to me um
in terms of uh
the moment in my life when i worked on
it
so i'm very glad it's special to other
people too uh yeah outside of just thank
you
it's amazing because we just
love what we do and we are so humbled to
see that it resonates with people so
yeah and it will make a
brighter future for arcane you know it's
a gift already and uh for the years to
come you know it's a great gift honestly
actually i have a last one like four
i mean
anecdotes uh
it's funny because generally like like
you have great resistance to jet lag man
funnily enough like to tell you how much
we are happy and and happy surprised
pleasantly surprised like this time no
one even made that bet
uh like no one was expecting
that so uh wow
really happy
[Music]
you